et on commence cette émission avec
Bernard jaumier bonjour bonjour vous
êtes sénateur de Paris membre du groupe
socialiste au Sénat on va commencer
cette interview par évoquer cette
élection à législative partielle en
arrière avec la victoire de la candidate
dissidente socialiste face à la députée
sortante insoumise qui était soutenue
par la nupes vous saluez à cette
victoire de Martine Froget bien sûr
parce que c'est une victoire d'une
candidate de gauche c'est incontestable
à la gauche elle est diverses pour
qu'elle gagne il y a toujours deux
conditions d'abord il faut rassembler
largement et puis il faut savoir aussi
dépasser nos propres frontières et
d'ailleurs c'est pas propre ça à une
partie ou autre de la gauche je j'ai
souvenir de beaucoup de discours de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon où il appelle les
républicains ce qui est un terme très
large qui fait appel à un éventail
politique très large à se mobiliser dans
dans des élections donc voilà Martin
Froget a gagné elle était très soutenue
localement
porte une ligne politique qui est
clairement de gauche mais qui est aussi
une ligne de rassemblement je crois que
doivent s'interroger ceux qui ont été
battus dès le premier tour le
rassemblement national et Renaissance la
majorité présidentielle 10% au premier
tour et puis doit s'interroger la
députée sortante qui a perdu du terrain
par rapport à l'élection précédente au
premier tour et je crois que les
insomnies doivent n'ont pas chercher des
responsables ailleurs à gauche mais se
poser des questions sur eux-mêmes pour
vous c'est pas un problème que cette
candidate dissidente socialiste soit élu
avec les voix de la droite mais quand
vous vous êtes au second tour d'une
élection
au second tour on élimine comme on dit
et donc effectivement il y a eu
clairement des électeurs un message qui
a été adressé aux insoumis il faut
regarder les choses en face et les dire
sans détour et je crois que ce qui a été
l'attitude politique de la France
insoumise dans la séquence passée a eu
des conséquences direct et que les
électeurs y compris les électeurs de
gauche et les électeurs ont dit voilà
nous c'est de cette gauche qu'on veut
plutôt et pas de celle-là il faut pas
accroître les tensions à partir de ça il
faut pas en faire un événement politique
national on connaît depuis longtemps ces
diverses y compris stratégiques à gauche
il faut savoir les dépasser accueillir
Martin projet comme il se doit à
l'Assemblée nationale et continuer à
gauche dans le groupe socialiste je ne
suis pas séisme mais c'est l'affaire du
PS mais je ne comprendrais pas pourquoi
un parti qui a une candidate qui a gagné
une élection la mettrait au banc et la
refuserait dans ses rangs ce ne serait
pas un signe de rassemblement de la
gauche pour le coup alors effectivement
je le précise vous êtes membre du groupe
socialiste au Sénat mais vous n'êtes pas
membre du Parti socialiste finalement
d'ici 2027 comment doit se jouer à
l'avenir de la gauche est-ce qu'il doit
se préparer en dehors de la nups ou
est-ce qu'il faut revoir cette alliance
de la nups avec et bien moins de
domination des insoumis
alors la nuit UPS c'est une construction
électorale qui est issue de la dernière
présidentielle bon et qui fait que à
gauche la France insoumise est en
situation on va dire de domination c'est
de loin le mouvement qui a le plus de
députés et donc candidat avait fait et
de loin le meilleur score à l'élection
présidentielle est-ce que cette
conformation est en capacité de
rassembler suffisamment de français pour
conquérir le pouvoir parce que quand on
est des mouvements politiques on veut
exercer les responsabilités au
gouvernement j'en suis pas convaincu
parce que on aura semble jamais avec le
mouvement le plus déporté en termes de
radicalité politique qui est dominant
c'est c'est l'histoire politique de
notre pays et c'est la réalité politique
aujourd'hui de notre pays donc une
gauche qui est dominée par la France
insoumise avec la méthode politique
qu'on a vu à l'oeuvre ces derniers temps
à peu de chance il faut le dire de
conquérir le pouvoir dans notre pays
donc ça ça ne vaut pas non plus
d'exclusion de qui que ce soit de la
gauche moi je ne fais pas partie non
plus de ceux qui disent que les insoumis
doivent être rejetés hors du champ de la
gauche évidemment que non on doit
rassembler l'ensemble des forces qui
existent actuellement et on doit avoir
un centre politique un barycentre c'est
à dire pour prendre un terme
mathématique un centre d'équilibre
politique qui soit différent de ce qui
est su la dernière élection
présidentielle des personnalités comme
Carole Delga ou Bernard Cazeneuve
peuvent incarner ce centre à gauche
alors peuvent incarner le centre de la
gauche mais je ne suis pas certain
l'équilibre politique soit exactement là
non plus on va parler de la réforme des
retraites de Bernard giomier avec la
première ministre Elisabeth borne qui va
consulter les syndicats mercredi des
syndicats Unis en inter syndicale est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est consultations
peuvent mener à quelque chose
alors d'abord les syndicats moi je me
satisfaits qu'ils ont été répondu à
l'investation de la première ministre je
regrette que le chef de l'État n'est pas
organisé une conférence sociale à
l'Elysée c'est lui qui a inspiré cette
réforme des retraites dans les
conditions qu'on a vu c'est lui qui
imposé la brutalité de la méthode pour
faire passer au forceps sa réforme des
retraites c'était à lui d'inviter à une
grande conférence sociale à l'Élysée
c'est la première ministre qui le fait
les organisations syndicales y vont on
verra ce qu'il en sort mais je crains
que la première ministre ne voulant pas
rediscuter de la loi qui est passée au
49.3 à l'Assemblée nationale je crains
qu'il n'y ait pas d'accord évidemment à
la sortie de cette réunion et donc la
balle si je puis dire la suite va
revenir dans le champ politique on
attend la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel et il faut être très
clair s'il y avait ne serait-ce que
censure partielle de certaines
dispositions ça remettrait profondément
en cause le texte car y compris les
auteurs du texte ont défendu l'idée que
la mesure de report à 64 ans était
atténué était compensé par un certain
nombre de mesures d'accompagnement si
une seule de ces mesures
d'accompagnement était invalidée par le
Conseil constitutionnel je pense à
l'index seniors en particulier et bien
le texte serait encore plus inacceptable
que ce qu'il n'est actuellement donc
tout ça n'est pas terminé il faut
absolument que suite à cette rencontre
les mouvements politiques
réaffirment très fortement que cette
réforme
avec ce mode d'adoption et avec ce
contenu ne doit pas être appliqué il
faut la retirer alors en tout cas elle
est parti politique sont également
consultés par la première ministre cette
semaine mais plutôt sur la suite du
quinquennat Elisabeth borne qui doit
monter un nouveau programme législatif
les parlementaires de gauche ont d'ores
et déjà dit qu'ils ne souhaitaient pas
participer à ces consultations ils ont
raison de refuser oui bien sûr parce que
la première chose c'est que vous voyez
il n'y a pas de majorité politique on
l'a vu on l'a vu avec ce texte sur la
réforme de retraite s'il avait été mis à
l'Assemblée nationale probablement qui
n'était pas adopté lors des dernières
législatives les Français avec cette
composition de l'Assemblée nationale
envoyait un message au monde politique
c'est à dire un message de demande de
compromis il n'y a pas de majorité
absolue et donc ils ont demandé aux
forces politiques en quelque sorte de
savoir faire preuve de compromis
café le gouvernement il a utilisé la
pire brutalité pour faire adopter sa
réforme des retraites c'est à dire et
les Français s'ils sont pas trompés qui
ont rejeté massivement du coup cette
réforme voilà le gouvernement est non
seulement le 49-3 mais tout un ensemble
d'autres outils constitutionnels pour
forcer l'adoption c'était c'est
l'inverse en terme de méthode de ce
qu'il fallait faire alors maintenant la
première ministre maintenant qu'elle
constate des dégâts qu'elle voit que
plus personne ne vaut voter un texte
important ici au Sénat on avait la
semaine dernière à l'ordre du jour une
loi sur l'immigration qui a été retirée
au dernier moment par le gouvernement
parce qu'il voyait bien que personne ne
voulait voter son texte de loi et donc
face à cette situation politique la
seule les seuls issues démocratiques
c'est soit de redonner la parole au
peuple soit la démission du gouvernement
et la nomination d'un nouveau
gouvernement qui se représente devant
l'Assemblée nationale pour obtenir un
vote de confiance il n'y a pas d'autre
issus politiques alors je le disais pas
de discussion entre les parlementaires
de gauche et la première ministre mais
mardi les parlementaires communistes et
insoumis et même les parlementaires
écologistes vont marcher vers l’élysée
pour protester contre la réforme des
retraites également pour remettre une
lettre au président de la République
c'est une bonne démarche selon vous
cette marche vers l'Élysée
moi je constate qu'on a un gouvernement
qui joue sans cesse la stratégie de la
tension et que c'est dangereux dans
l'état actuel du pays et on le voit sur
chaque dossier on a vu monsieur Darmanin
encore ce week-end qui taxe des
oppositions de gauche de terrorisme
intellectuel les mots intenses c'est
inacceptable dans le débat démocratique
d'utiliser ce terme d'expression donc il
y a une stratégie de la tension alors
qu'il faudrait chercher le compromis et
moi je ne souhaite pas qu'on nourrisse
cette stratégie de l'attention soyons
plus responsables que le gouvernement
des parlementaires qui marchent vers
l'Elysée même si cette façon pacifique
et gênante doute pas je ne pense pas que
ce soit un bon message je pense qu'il y
a dans notre position très ferme de
rejet des méthodes du gouvernement et du
fond de la réforme des retraites il faut
s'en tenir à ce qui est conforme à nos
tradition on va dire républicaine et
n'est pas dans notre additions
républicaine que des parlementaires
marchent sur l'Élysée pourquoi ce n'est
pas un message il y a un symbole
révolutionnaire d'ailleurs cette arche
devant le palais présidentiel parce que
effectivement on a croit on accro à
l'attention l'exécutif le gouvernement
Emmanuel Macron ont un comportement
brutal avec les parlementaires nous ne
devons pas en retour avoir un
comportement brutal avec Emmanuel Macron
nous devons au contraire projeter une
opposition qui résolue qui est
déterminée qui ne lâche rien du tout
mais qui dans ces méthodes appelle un
toujours à la participation au large
rassemblement à la concorde nationale et
non pas à une tension qui fait l'affaire
au fond du gouvernement Bernard jaumier
vous êtes vice-président de la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat médecin de profession on va
justement parler de la question des
soignants puisque le gouvernement va
mettre fin à l'obligation à vaccinale
des soignants contre la covid 19 et donc
réintégrer à les soignants non vaccinés
qui avaient été suspendus c'est une
décision qui suit la vie de la Haute
Autorité de Santé vous le regrettez
oui je le regrette oui je le regrette
parce que voyez-vous l'épidémie de covid
n'a plus le caractère aigu qu'elle a pu
avoir qu'on a connu ça ne veut pas dire
qu'elle a disparu et l'obligation
vaccinale des soignants ça fait écho à
des valeurs qui sont des valeurs des
soignants qui est d'accepter
en l'occurrence la vaccination pour
protéger les plus vulnérables et là le
message qu'on voit le gouvernement parce
que ce n'est pas que sur la vaccination
covid que porte le rapport de la Haute
Autorité de santé c'est un message de
virage à 180 degrés par rapport à la loi
de 2018 qui est la dernière grande étape
en matière de vaccination en 2018 le
Parlement a voté la vaccination une
vaccination obligatoire pardon pour
toute la population pour 11 maladies
évidemment pour les soignants aussi et
bien il se trouve que il y a très peu de
temps une quinzaine de jours on a eu
évaluation de cette décision et que
c'est un succès absolu c'est à dire que
des maladies comme la rougeole ou le
taux de vaccination plafonné à 85% dans
notre pays c'est-à-dire que ça continue
à circuler et rappelez-vous au moment où
débattait en 2018 une jeune femme est
décédée en Charente de la rougeole et
bien du fait de cette obligation
vaccinale étendue on a passé les 95% et
donc on va vers l'éradication de ces
maladies donc c'est une faute politique
que d'envoyer un message qui est de
reculer sur la vaccination obligatoire
parce que des antivax qui sont ultra
minoritaires se sont mobilisés c'est une
façon en gros de d'envoyer une claque à
la figure des soignants qui eux
l'Académie de médecine le rappelait dans
son communiqué il y a quelques jours
sont attachés à cette notion parce que
c'est l'honneur d'une profession que de
prendre soin des plus vulnérables
comment vous expliquer ce changement de
pied de la Haute Autorité de Santé et du
gouvernement sur cette obligation
vaccinale CCD à certains mouvements dans
l'opinion alors je note d'abord que la
Haute Autorité santé dit bien dans son
avis qui est très argumenté quelle se
base sur des données microbiologiques et
épidémiologiques pardon pour la
technicité de ces termes mais elle en
appelle à la vie du CCNE du Comité
national d'éthique parce que une
obligation vaccinale c'est aussi une
question culturelle d'intérêt général
etc il y a un fondement scientifique et
il y a des données sociologiques et
culturelles le gouvernement n'a pas
attendu la vie du CCNE il s'est
précipité je pense que c'est un message
politique oui Bernard on va parler de la
fin de vie puisque aujourd'hui le
président de la République reçoit les
membres de la Convention citoyenne sur
leur fin de vie une sur la fin de vie
une convention citoyenne qui a terminé
ses travaux on en parle avec notre
journaliste Mathias sarez
[Musique]
bonjour Mathias bonjour Alexandre alors
dimanche la convention citoyenne sur la
fin de vie à terminer ses travaux une
convention citoyenne qui a été souhaitée
par Emmanuel Macron oui ça y est
Alexandre après quatre mois de travaux
les 184 citoyens tirés au sort ont fini
par rendre leur rapport soutenu à la
quasi unanimité 92% pour 3% contre et 5%
d'abstention et donc il devait répondre
à une question posée par Elisabeth borne
le cadre d'accompagnement de la fin de
vie est-il adapté aux différentes
situations rencontrées ou d'éventuelles
changements devraient-ils être introduit
et bien leur réponse est que le cadre
actuel d'accompagnement de la fin de vie
n'est pas adaptée aux différentes
situations rencontrées principalement
pour deux raisons d'un côté l'inégalité
d'accès à l'accompagnement de la fin de
vie et de l'autre l'absence de réponse
satisfaisante face à certaines
situations de fin de vie notamment dans
le cas de souffrance physique ou
psychique réfractaire et alors quel
changement doivent être introduits
Mathias et bien par de nombreuses
recommandations et notamment sur les
moyens qui doivent être alloués à
l'accès aux soins palliatifs une sort du
lot Alexandre selon les conventionnelles
il faut ouvrir l'accès à l'aide actif à
mourir pour trois conventionnelles sur 4
en mettant en place à la fois le suicide
assisté et le thanazi alors avec des
critères précis tout d'abord la volonté
délibérée et que le discernement soit
systématiquement pris en compte ensuite
l'âge la convention n'a pas réussi à
statuer sur la possibilité ou non de
l'ouvrir aux mineurs il s'en tient donc
au majeur seulement et enfin évidemment
la condition médicale c'est à dire la
prise en compte de critères
d'incurabilité ou de souffrance physique
alors Bernard jaumier en 2021 vous
n'aviez pas voté la proposition de loi
de votre collègue Marie-Pierre de la
Gontrie sur ce sujet car le CADA le
cadrage n'était pas suffisant selon vous
est-ce que dans ces recommandations vous
voyez une ligne plus claire
alors moi d'abord je salue on vous le
travail de cette convention citoyenne
donc qui est extrêmement fouillé dont le
rapport est extrêmement complexe
d'ailleurs parce qu'il introduit tout un
certain nombre de critères qui
effectivement font toute la complexité
de la décision mais pour essayer de
d'éclaircir le débat d'abord il y a un
constat unanime c'est que les soins
palliatifs et la convention citoyenne
propose ce constat aussi sont
insuffisamment développés dans notre
pays et que c'est la source d'une grande
partie des difficultés et je le dis on
va le répéter sans arrêt et ça ne se
traduit pas en acte derrière et ces
problématiques parce que c'est aussi ce
qui fait une exaspération une inégalité
d'accès dans les conditions de fin de
vie de nos concitoyens mais ça n'épuise
pas le débat parce que malgré tout la
législation actuelle souffre d'une
inadaptation pourquoi parce qu'on a un
principe dans notre droit dans votre
droit y compris lors de l'étude et
dernière loi de bioéthique qui est un
principe qui est en train de se
développer et que je soutiens qui est le
principe d'autonomie cette autonomie de
la personne et reconnue de plus en plus
dans notre législation et en la matière
la reconnaissance du principe
d'autonomie doit amener à modifier la
loi pour reconnaître le droit à ce
qu'ils appellent l'aide active à mourir
après tout principe se confronte à
d'autres principes et il y a un autre
principe et auquel moi je suis très
attaché et c'est pour ça que je n'avais
pas voté la proposition de loi de ma
collègue c'est que la profession
soignante doit être respecté dans ces
valeurs fondamentales et la valeur
fondamentale du soin c'est de ne pas
administrer la mort c'est d'une des
valeurs fondamentales et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis favorable
en gros au modèle suisse ou c'est à dire
le suicide je ne suis pas favorable à
l'euthanasie c'est-à-dire c'est le
soignant canisse la mort et d'ailleurs
la convention citoyenne va au cœur de ce
débat et dire on pourrait légaliser le
suicide assisté avec ce qu'on appelle
une exception de thanazisme c'est-à-dire
il est exact que dans un certain cas la
personne n'est pas en capacité de
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre ce droit et
donc il y a une exception de
l'euthanasie qui est ouverte ce sont des
débats fondamentaux parce qu'ils
appellent aux valeurs fondamentales de
notre société je crois profondément
qu'un consensus est possible je crois
qu'un consensus est possible si on
conjugue ces deux principes le principe
d'autonomie des personnes que d'autres
appellent libre choix et les valeurs des
soignants alors Mathias quelle va être
la suite de ce rapport de la convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie alors vous
le disiez Alexandre il sera remis
aujourd'hui au président de la
République par les membres de la
Convention citoyenne mais comme pour la
convention citoyenne pour le climat à
l'époque cet avis n'est que consult et
n'a rien de contraignant alors à lui de
décider de l'exploitation de cette
matière de cette réflexion Bernard
jaumier Emmanuel Macron doit-il se
saisir totalement de cet avis qu'est-ce
qu'il doit faire finalement de cette
matière c'est le Parlement qui fait la
loi donc d'abord je pense que je le dis
très très solennellement ce n'est pas un
chef de l'État seul qui va on verra ce
changement de législation sociétale de
toute façon c'est le Parlement qui vote
la loi moi j'appelle Emmanuel Macron a
laissé justement le Parlement délibéré
et à lui donner le temps de délibérer
c'est à dire non pas inscrire le texte
dans longtemps alors du jour dans 6 mois
ou un an à l'inscrire assez rapidement
par exemple à la rentrée parlementaire
dès après l'été et à laisser le
Parlement justement aller au bout de ces
questions par des débats approfondis par
des débats des passionnés et poser le
cadre qui permet que tous nos citoyens
accès aux soins palliatifs et que leur
soit ouvert un nouveau droit c'est à
dire vous appelez plutôt à une
proposition de loi qui émanerait d'un
parlementaire plutôt qu'un projet de loi
porté par le gouvernement alors ça je
dirais que peu importe si ce n'est
qu'effectivement le projet de loi est
plus simple en terme de mécanique
parlementaire mais ce qui est
indispensable surtout c'est que le chef
de l'État ne cherche pas à faire
prévaloir son point de vue personnel
mais qui laisse la représentation
nationale délibérée merci beaucoup
Mathias on vous retrouvera dans le club
des territoires on parlera dans certains
Gérald Darmanin
on va parler maintenant des trottinettes
en libre-service et on va retrouver nos
partenaires du journal du Grand Paris
avec Jacques paquet qui est directeur de
la rédaction du journal du Grand Paris
Jacques on va revenir avec vous sur la
votation citoyenne qui a été organisée
hier à Paris sur à ces trottinettes en
libre-service
mais tout à fait bonjour oui absolument
un million
382322 parisiens étaient appelés à se
prononcer hier 1034 on fait le
déplacement ça donne un taux de
participation de 7,46%
89,03% sont prononcés contre
10,97% pour donc les trottinettes en
free flotting en livre service monsieur
le sénateur j'aurais souhaité que vous
commentiez ce résultat j'ai deux petites
questions est-ce que c'est bien bordé
juridiquement autrement dit il
suffira-t-il de ne pas reconduire la
concession la concession pardon
d'occupation temporaire du domaine
public pour que les trois opérateurs qui
restent présents disparaissent et puis
deuxième question n'est ce pas là un
parfait exemple de la nécessité de de
prendre en compte la totalité du cycle
de vie d'un produit pour évaluer son
empreinte carbone
bonjour d'abord moi je trouve que plus
de 100 000 Parisiens qui seront aux
urnes pour une première parce qu'il n'y
avait jamais eu de votation organisées
dans notre vie en dehors des cycles
électoraux je trouve que c'est tout de
même satisfait j'ai beaucoup entendu
l'opposition railler cette consultation
dire que personne n'ira aux urne donc
c'est pour une première parce que ce
n'est qu'une première c'est satisfaisant
la démocratie participative doit prendre
plus de place dans notre pays aux côtés
de la démocratie représentative sur le
fond je crois que les Parisiens ont
exprimé un vote très clair que vous
l'avez vous avez cité les chiffres et
que ils ont intégré à la fois la
question des nouveaux partages de
l'espace public qui sont en mutation on
a connu la période où l'espace public
c'était massivement la voiture les
piétons on a vu l'émergence du vélo
arriver le conflit automobile vélo et
puis de nouveaux engins de sont apparues
et de nouvelles nouveaux conflits
d'usage sont apparus dans l'espace
public avec les trottinettes et puis les
deux roues motorisées qui ont pris aussi
beaucoup d'importance à Paris et donc il
nous faut réguler tout ça et le message
je crois qu'on voulait envoyer les
Parisiens c'est que dans cette
régulation il faut prendre en compte
avant tous les plus faibles dans
l'espace public qui sont les piétons
parce que c'est eux qui principalement
sont les victimes des accidents de
trottinette après j'ai bien entendu les
plus écologistes ont pris en compte ce
que vous relevez c'est-à-dire le cycle
de vie des trottinettes mais d'ailleurs
qui qui va se poser la même façon pour
les voitures électriques c'est-à-dire
que les batteries des trottinettes parce
qu'elles sont à peu près tout
électriques elles sont même toutes
électriques les trottinettes en free
flotting et bien on ne sait pas trop
quoi en faire en fin de vie un certain
nombre finissent d'ailleurs au fond de
la scène mais les voitures électriques
nous allons faire face à la même
question écologique
donc je crois que les Parisiens ont
voulu envoyer ce message la mère de
Paris a eu bien raison d'abord de leur
donner la parole et de solliciter leur
avis et elle a annoncé d'ailleurs à la
lancer un travail très important sur ce
qu'on appelle le code de la rue et on a
un code de la route parce qu'il est
organisé au temps de la voiture mais
dans nos villes il faut qu'on ait un
code de la rue qui prennent mieux en
compte les nouveaux usages et ses
nouvelles mobilités merci beaucoup
Jacques paquet pour votre intervention
je vais rappeler elle a une du journal
du Grand Paris sur l'inflation qui
perturbe le secteur des travaux publics
Merci à VOUS Bernard Chaumier dernière
question rapidement sur les élections
sanitaires sénatoriales à Paris la maire
de Paris Anne Hidalgo est plutôt pour
une liste commune entre les socialistes
les communistes peut-être même les
écologistes vous êtes favorable ah moi
je suis favorable à une liste de toute
la majorité municipale au projet des
élections sénatoriales ça ne posera pas
de problème de siège pour laisser un
tort socialistes actuels c'est la seule
façon même de gagner un siège de plus
pour la gauche et vous pensez que ce
sera le cas
je l'espère c'est aux écologistes il
semble que les communistes y soient
prêts c'est aux écologistes à dire ce
qu'ils souhaitent la balle est dans le
camp des écologistes à Paris merci
beaucoup Bernard jaumier d'avoir été le
sénateur du jour dans 20 minutes ce sera
le club des territoires nous reviendrons
sur les consultations que doit mener la
première ministre Elisabeth borne cette
semaine avec les syndicats et les partis
politiques Bernard jaumier vous allez
laisser votre place à notre invité
politique aujourd'hui c'est Manuel
Bompard le coordinateur de la France
insoumise député des Bouches-du-Rhône